you probably know that there is nothing
resolved about the Donald Trump Russia
scandal currently there are three
investigations there's a house committee
a Senate committee and the FBI at
minimum somehow though Sean Spicer
Trump's hairbrained press secretary has
gotten it into his mind that the Trump
Russia situation is case closed
nothing to see here everybody's been
cleared he was asked about inquiries on
the matter in a recent press briefing
and he declared that everybody who's
been briefed about it has said that
there's really nothing here there's no
coordination there's no connection
between Trump Russia this is a done deal
which is a surprise to anybody who's
aware of the minimum of three
investigations that are going on here
Sean Spicer himself every single person
who's been briefed on this as I've said
ad nauseam from this podium that they've
been very clear that there is no
connection between the president or the
staff here and anyone doing anything
with Russia every single person who has
been briefed on the situation with
respect to the the situation with Russia
Republican Democrat Obama appointee
career have all come to the same
conclusion where is Spicer coming up
with this stuff it's it couldn't be more
opposite case closed I feel like we've
barely even started to get to the bottom
of this and even the people involved in
the investigations are saying it could
be a while until these investigations
are finished and the thing is if the
White House wasn't actually concerned
you'd think they would just say well
there's an investigation going on we're
going to cooperate we're willing to see
what the evidence is we support it
because it's gonna clear this yeah we're
gonna be proven innocent by the end of
this taking the opposite approach is
what he's doing here should Spicer be on
suicide watch and I say this because
he's got to be struggling here
destroying his career making a fool out
of himself starting on day one of the
presidency lying about the the crowd at
Trump's inauguration and then just lying
and lying and lying he's got to be
feeling like a joke when he goes to bed
every night though I think at this point
he realizes there's no way to redeem
himself because he's already considered
a hatchet man and has been since day one
do you think he maybe believes if he
says it enough people will say oh yeah
the investigations are over even though
they're not like is it
those if you repeat a lie enough it
becomes the truth type of things I don't
know it's tough to say with pathological
liars he could he definitely could do
you believe he is personally a
pathological liar
or do you think he's just basically
doing the bidding of the Trump in the
administration and he recognized that
this is BS I think it's more likely that
Donald Trump is a pathological liar and
he's just translator that just has to
say the words of the president directly
although Sean Spicer has tweeted out his
passwords twice and that's not exactly
what somebody who uh yeah maybe we
shouldn't even rehash that but he did
twice tweet out passwords did it's just
that when you change your password it's
never asked if you want to tweet that
everyone like there's never an option
sometimes when you finish a booking on
Expedia it says press this button to
tweet to your friends that you're going
to Mexico or something like that when
you change your password you're not
usually given the option to say hey let
your friends know what your new password
is type of thing and yet somehow he
managed to tweet out his password twice
discuss this with us on our reddit
discussion forum david pakman.com slash
our EDD IT today's episode of the david
pakman show is made possible in part by
Warby Parker eyeglasses Warby Parker
recently did the right thing and ditched
advertising on right-wing conspiracy
website Breitbart pulling their ads off
and you can get the free five-day home
Tryon from Warby Parker check out their
glasses I use them when I'm not wearing
contact lenses I started with the free
at-home trial they send you five pairs
of glasses you see which ones you like
you send them back and whichever one you
pick they will put your prescription in
- I like this because I can actually
show the glasses to other people and not
have to just decide on the spot like in
an eyeglass store the eyeglass industry
is controlled by very few corporations
that keep the prices very very high even
over $300 for prescription glasses with
Warby Parker they start at just 95 bucks
mine costs that including lenses and for
every pair sold they give a pair to
someone in need so to try the five pairs
and support the David Pakman show go to
Warby Parker trial comm for
/ TDPS